we should not go looking at Egypt as if
it's a successful revolution it's not
it's a managed transition Mubarak is
gone the military is still there and
will be the most powerful player in that
country for a long time there will be a
democratically elected government and
that's a good thing but it will be a
weak government it will have weak
political parties it will probably form
week coalition's that will have a very
hard time actually getting meaningful
political and economic reform done so is
Egypt a success story well it's not like
Iran where the demonstrators were
brutally repressed but it's also not
like Georgia where you ended up with a
complete shift of regime so great on the
political economic and security front
that the Russians invaded them a few
years later now that my friends is a
successful revolution Egypt is a managed
transition it's kind of right in between
the two and in the United States the
media you know Time magazine has phases
of the Egyptian revolution and they look
beautiful and they speak English and all
that is wonderful but it doesn't really
reflect the reality on the ground of
what's actually happened across the
entirety of Egypt as we move from the
CNN to the c-span phase of Egypt which
is the phase that nobody actually
watches and it gets a little more boring
but where governance actually gets done
up we're going to find that the
transition in Egypt is a little less
dramatic than what was being reported in
the early days